how do you handle the slap herd round
the world have you given that thought
well that yes I have given it much
thought I think I have some good things
to to say about it um I think that it's
going to be on everybody's mind
everybody's gonna be waiting for that
moment that will be part of the show but
certainly not the focus of the show I'll
tell you what nobody got hit when I
hosted this no that's true you had a
very under control crowd just Rogue
envelopes this is not a joke Moonlight
has won best picture
Moonlight best picture everybody was
very well behaved at my Oscars right
yeah so what the heck happened I don't
know what happened I still can't believe
it happened it was suddenly a WWE event
oh wow
wow wow